hallo zusammen schönen abend ich war
jetzt schon länger nicht mehr mit euch
gemeinsam im garten
ich habe gedacht wir machen jetzt ganz
spontan einfach einen garten rundgang
bei uns geht nämlich gerade die sonne
unter und hier sind jetzt hinterm haus
und abends mal ganz schönen abend haben
wir nämlich ja am spielhaus perfekt die
sonne ist da auch nicht so kalt und im
mädels die tour dann hier noch rum und
was ihr euch wirklich zeigen muss es
sind hier die pflanzen die sind einfach
richtig explodiert wir haben dir
wirklich vor drei jahren mal
eingepflanzt und seitdem im prinzip hier
jetzt zumindest im hochbeet gar nichts
mehr also das recht einfach alles jedes
mal guckt mal und dann ist es täglich
sein ort und dem auch so kleine bienen
und hummeln immer wieder herkommen
da unsere gartenhaus hier drüben bauen
jetzt die nachbarn aber bald
nachbarschaft da hier guckt mal am
olivenbaum das auch vor also das liebe
ich vor allem abends hier weil wir hier
in uniform haben hier immer wenn du
direkt unter und rosmarin
also echt voll die oase und dann kann
ich euch noch von primera zeigen elmira
ist ja unsere eigene apfelsorte dass die
hier die wächst auch schon richtig toll
die mit wird ein bisschen stabilisieren
die clique nämlich so ein bisschen nach
hinten
die sind ein bisschen zu schnell
gewachsen aber das kriegen wir hin und
dann wird es auch wieder schön war von
ihrer macht hula-hoop im garten auch
schön
er betrat noch brote gebacken sechs
stück weil wir morgen besuch bekommen
und es geht um unsere neuen daten die
neuen praktischen aber sechsmal gemacht
damit ein gebot 1 bis 6 sonst ein
dunkles brot oder alle möglichen posten
und jetzt gibt es aber auch kartoffeln
brot und mediterranes und saft rot also
richtig sparen kann man glaube ich auch
schon ein bisschen ein paar tage dürfen
sie noch reifen aber dann habe im
prinzip schon unsere schönen kirchen
letztes jahr hatten wir leider keine
kirschernte und auch keine aprikosen da
sind nämlich die blüten weggefahren
dieses hier sehe ich ein paar aprikosen
aber leider auch nicht so viele weil es
doch anfang des jahres so warm war und
dann wurde wieder kalt ja und dann war
es einfach wieder weg dann aber hier
unseren schönen tisch mit den frischen
da muss jetzt aber mal wieder entdeckt
werden und hier drüben unsere hochbeete
da habe ich zum salat hochbeet als so
ein bisschen knobloch nicht knoblauch
sondern knobloch knobloch ist im prinzip
wie schnittlauch und knoblauch so in
einem dann sauerampfer die habe ich
petersilie rucola dahinten
frühlingszwiebeln haben wir jetzt auch
schon tomaten gepflanzt und salat ist
der salat liebhaber ja ein richtiger
salat oder kaviar
wir gehen gleich in sally conway er über
viel sommer hier
ok ich komme auch sofort gesagt ich mach
mich darauf mein video fertig hier ist
unsere minze also münzen sollte man
eigentlich nicht in ein hochbeet setzen
weil man sich einfach mega verbreitet
und ausbreitet man sieht hier
naja egal es gibt schlimmeres und hier
haben wir dann hier sieht so ein
bisschen leer aus aber es wird auch hohl
und zwar so dass kleine paprika peperoni
und chilis team wachsen häsler und damit
die seite zur terrasse hin immer schön
auf
sie habe ich dort lavendel und schnitten
auch hin gemacht weil es dann einfach
immer wächst und immer schön ist und
dann haben wir hier direkt bei der
lounge sozusagen haben wir auch nochmal
salate und ganz wichtig broccoli
romanesco und sogar kohlrabi hatte
manchmal den kopf seht ihr ihn da hinten
ist der kohlrabi hinterm rosmarin und
ich geb dir blumentöpfe
wir haben von einer freundin ganz viele
bekommen die sie extra für uns gemacht
hat und jetzt schauen wir mal ne granate
hall oder jetzt versuche ich noch
vorsätzlich versucht werde es den abend
genießen ich geh jetzt noch kurz murat
rüber ins silicon valley
da schaue ich mir mal an wie weit die
regale gekommen sind denn wir haben
heute regale bekommt regalsystemen und
hier sitze ich dann morgens gerne oder
abends wenn ich mir die zeit nehme ich
muss sagen bisher habe ich dieses jahr
den garten und nicht so viel genießen
kann
aber jetzt die zeit vom reck waren zählt
nicht dazu aber jetzt versuche ich jeden
abend zumindest raus zu gehen und
morgens auch mal so ein bisschen auf die
terrasse zu sitzen
der mann muss das leben auch genießen ja
aber heute habe ich wie gesagt ganz viel
gebacken weil ich morgen noch am besuch
da hab ich mache gern
mir ist einfach nur wichtig dass die
kinder jeden tag draußen sein und das
sind sie gerade eben haben wir noch mit
olga gemalt oktober arbeitet bei uns in
mannheim noch gearbeitet im shop und
jetzt haben auch bei uns hier ist echt
schön und haben sich die mädels
hingewirkt und mit ihnen gemeinsam
gemalt das von ganz alleine gewohnt und
samira hat auch ein megabit gemacht
ein hamburger und das habt ihr da noch
auf tik tok hochgeladen was habt ihr das
gehört das war eine karte war ein heute
wir haben nämlich im teich ganz viele
kröten die haben wir nicht
holt die kommen einfach von ganz alleine
aber gut bevor sie jetzt zu spät herz
und dunkel wird gehe ich jetzt zum murat
und wir sehen uns neuen lieder